cet invité c'est vincent de michel
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
conseiller océans au pacte mondial des
nations unies directeur des programmes
agroalimentaire à la fondation l'oeil de
resister de londres auteur de la
révolution des algues et vous répondez à
nos questions depuis brest où se tient
ce sommet sur l'océan le wii motion son
mythe les travaux vincent de mai elle
s'achève ce vendredi quel premier bilan
vous en tirez
j'en tire qui a une réelle prise de
conscience sur le l'urgence à agir de
manière coordonnée entre les pays sur
les océans ce qui est relativement
récent et skrela est ce qui est
extrêmement important il existe aucun
cadre de coopération contraignant entre
pays au niveau des océans on n'a aucune
agence qui permet de travailler ensemble
il ya rien de plus commun que les océans
qui soutiennent notre notre climat qui
soutiennent notre biodiversité qui
produisent notre oxygène et qui sont
aujourd'hui en grand grand danger donc
le fait de créer ce mouvement c'est la
première réunion une grande série on
l'espère
c'est extrêmement important encore une
fois agir au niveau national sur les
océans ça n'a aucun sens et il est temps
de mettre tous ensemble on a une agence
pour l'alimentaire on a une agence pour
la santé oms on a une convention climat
mans n'a rien qui soutient l'océan qui
est pourtant connecter avec tout le
reste et qui est le plus important
peut-être la vie sur terre est né dans
l'océan il est il et il est à craindre
qu'elle commence à disparaître aussi si
elle doit disparaître et la question
aujourd'hui qui qui se posent à nous
c'est de savoir si on pourra sauver
encore sauver les océans elle est
d'autant plus importante que
les océans ne peuvent encore nous sauver
alors la france vincent de mai elle qui
organise ce sommet promet des solutions
et des engagements vous ce vendredi
matin vous allez rencontrer le président
français emmanuel macron qu'est ce que
vous allez lui dire
j'ai lui je lui mais je pense qu il le
sert et je lui ai réaffirmé l'importance
de 2,2 d'agir sur les océans et moi j'ai
mon j'ai ma spécialité sur les algues
encore une fois où la france les océans
générale offre de multiples solutions et
les algues étant le plus bas niveaux
trophiques dans l'océan c'est le
meilleur moyen c'est le meilleur endroit
où commence et où réparer les
écosystèmes au lieu de continuer à les
détruire on est dans une logique de
réparation c'est ce qu'il faut un
puncher come home idée on a détruit 50 %
des écosystèmes de l'océan on n'est plus
dans une logique de développement
durable sur le sujet on est vraiment
dans une logique de restauration
les algues vous en êtes un spécialiste
assez reconnu vincent de mais elle vous
avez publié ce livre aux éditions des
équateurs la révolution des algues vous
vous dites que elle représente
sensiblement le futur qu'est ce que
justement en termes de détails les
algues représentent pour le l'écosystème
marin et par extension pour la vie sur
la terre ferme
elles sont la source de tout en fait là
elles ont été les premiers organismes
multicellulaires complexe sur terre
elles sont là aujourd'hui la plus grande
ressource in exports inexploré et
inexploité au monde on ne les connaît
pas alors qu'elles fournissent une
solution à la faim dans le monde elles
peuvent nourrir les populations elles
peuvent nourrir les animaux elles
peuvent soutenir naturellement les
plantes elles peuvent remplacer le
plastique elles peuvent elles font le
premier niveau trophique et donc elles
vont fournir un habitat naturel et la
nourriture aux poissons aux petits
poissons hobby valvo aussitôt plantons
elles vont fournir des solutions
médicales
complètement innovante elles sont un
horizon d'innovation absolument inconnu
elles vont aussi absorber beaucoup de
carbone et donc contribuer à maintenir
le climat tel qu'il est à réduire le
changement climatique elles vont fournir
aussi et surtout des revenus ou aux
populations côtières
qui souffrent aujourd'hui qui sont
souvent ravagé par la misère dans les
pays émergents et où les ressources de
la pêche continue de diminuer et on sait
que ce sera inexorable afin de revenir à
l'océan 20102 mais elle les algues
toujours on pense quand même aux algues
vertes aux algues sargasse pour le coup
on est dedans tout à fait autre chose
que ce que vous décrivez
oui et non en fait française oui parce
que nous on souhaite passer à la cultive
la culture et c'est là c'est ça qu'on
appelle la révolution des algues c'est
de faire ce qu'on a fait il ya deux
mille ans sur terre de sortir de la
préhistoire est entré dans un livre dans
la civilisation et donc de sortir de la
préhistoire des algues de la préhistoire
de l'océan où on a encore des chasseurs
cueilleurs dans l'océan pour ce qui est
des algues vertes et des sargasses il
faut bien comprendre que ce sont les
algues sauvage déjà donc on n'a pas ces
problèmes là avec des algues cultivées
c'est bien encore une fois c'est l'idée
de passer delà de l'âge préhistorique à
la civilisation ou bien comprendre aussi
que ces algues on se saurait on serait
les valoriser on serait sans doute
peut-être les récolter la complexité
c'est de valoriser ce qui est le prix
d'une pollution ces algues ne sont pas
un problème en soi elles sont le
résultat d'un problème qui est la
pollution des sols qui se déversent dans
les océans et l'océan il fait comme
comme n'importe quel écosystème complexe
il
des
idées arrivent se protègent voilà et
donc ils déploient des algues pour
absorber les polluants pour absorber les
nutriments qui arrive c'est le cas en
cas dans les caraïbes avec l'embouchure
de l'amazone y est c'est le cas en dans
les dents les en bretagne avec avec
l'élevage intensif de porcs donc c'est
vraiment encore une fois le puits une
pollution qu'il faut cesser cette
méthode cette agriculture cse il faut
reconnecter la terre avec les océans et
là on voit bien que nos destins sont
liés qu'on ne pourra pas agir sur l'un
sans agir sur l'autre c'est dans ces
mots vincent de maizel pardonnez moi de
rappeler un l'essentiel des menaces qui
pèsent sur les océans on pense à
l'extrême pollution due aux plastiques
on pense à la perte de la biodiversité
au blanchissement des coraux on pense
aussi à l'acidification des eaux à la
surpêche au bruit aussi dans l'océan
puisque les
les animaux en soufre
50% de l'oxygène respiré sur notre
planète l'est du fait de l'océan que
nous connaissons pourtant très peu
vincent doumier elle comment expliquer
que nous en sachions autant sur une
ressource aussi vital
on en sait aussi peu en fait c'est vrai
qu'on n'a aucune connaissance des
mécanismes qui qui qui s'organise dans
l'océan on est dans une activité
purement extractives aujourd'hui
absolument pas régénérative qu'on
extrait des ressources de la pêche en
extrait des des ressources minières sans
aucune connaissance des des réactions en
chaîne que ça va ça va générer et ça on
joue vraiment avec le feu aujourd'hui on
a des on a tout le monde s'alarme des
forêts d'ailleurs dans les les en
amazonie mais on a des forêts sous les
océans qui disparaissent qui
disparaissent de manière inexorable
comme on a eu en californie qui entraîne
la destruction et l'extinction de 750
espèces pour ce qui est le cas de la
californie donc on a un ensemble de deux
paramètres qu'on ne connaît absolument
pas en effet et qu'il faut apprendre est
qu'il faut être pour faire de la
recherche sur les algues aujourd'hui le
principal problème pour qu'ils limitent
le potentiel des algues à résoudre les
grands problèmes de notre génération
c'est la ccl déficit de connaissances
qu'on a à les cultiver à les domestiquer
on connaît dix à vingt algues sur le
conseil domestique et dix à vingt algues
et sur les 12000 qui existe ce sont
essentiellement les asiatiques qui ont
pris de l'avancé sur le sujet et il nous
reste à connaître nos alliés apprendre
comment les cultiver une question sur la
france deuxième puissance maritime
mondiale après les états unis que fait
la france de ce potentiel
bah pas encore assez c'est certain en
tout cas on a on a vraiment un potentiel
énorme à ce niveau là il est temps de il
est temps d'avoir une stratégie je pense
que c'est aussi pour ça que dans le
cadre de la présidence française de
l'union européenne en a on a tenu à
mener cette action et qu'il est
important je pense que la france a un
énorme potentiel a joué la france le
l'océan offre beaucoup beaucoup de
solutions encore une part au grand défi
de notre génération est née la france
doit doit de se servir de cet avantage
qu'elle a et les grandes puissances de
demain si on sait servir de l'océan ce
conte sans doute pas du tout les mêmes
que les grandes puissances d'aujourd'hui
pour refermer sur une note positive ou
négative vous allez me dire l'une des
grandes préoccupations du moment est
liée à la gestion des ressources marines
il ya des projets d'exploitation des
grands-fonds qu'est ce que vous en
pensez est ce qu'il s'agit de progrès
techniques progrès humain où vous dites
projet de saccage environnemental
il faut il faut faire les choses de
manière raisonnable et en apprenant de
notre expérience sur terre banques il
faut d'abord comprendre les écosystèmes
d'abord les réactions en chaîne d'abord
met la science en premier et quand on
aura compris l'ensemble il ne faut rien
proscrire mais il faut d'abord
comprendre il faut d'abord maîtriser ce
qui va se passer on ne peut pas rentrer
dans les logiques qui ont vu la
monoculture le des ogm ou là où
l'agriculture industrielle dans les
océans il faut éviter à tout prix ça il
faut développer une permaculture
respectueuse des écosystèmes est
absolument régénérative c est mon
message merci beaucoup vincent de mai
elle d'avoir répondu à nos questions
depuis brest où se tient ce one run sa
mitre vincendo mais elle conseillé
océans au pacte mondial des nations
unies ce était l'invité de paille direct
merci de rester sur nos chaînes